PROFESSOR: The simplest bound
that a random variable differs
by much from its expectation
is due to a guy named Markov,
a Russian probability theorist.
And this is Markov's bound
that we're going to talk about.
Let's illustrate it with
a memorable example of IQ.
In the MIT context, it
may be a radical idea.
But IQ was this thing
that was invented
for intelligence quotient in the
late 19th century, I believe.
Might have been early 20th.
It was meant as
an effort to break
the mold at Harvard of hiring
the children of wealthy alumni.
And the idea was to have
merit-based admissions.
And it was going to be
some objective measure that
did not depend on social class
of the ability that people had.
And Harvard was going
to admit students
based on merit and their
intelligence quotient.
So the original design of
the intelligent quotient
by a bunch of psychologists was
that the average was supposed
to be 100 over the
whole population, which,
of course, is-- around
here, there just
aren't very many people
with an IQ of just 100.
Anyway, let's ask
this extreme question.
Yes, around the
elite universities,
there are a lot of people
with IQs much higher than 100.
But what fraction
of the population
could possibly have
an IQ as high as 300?
Now, I'm not sure that
an IQ of as high as 300
has ever been recorded.
But we're talking
logically here.
Is it possible for
a lot of people
to have an IQ of greater
than or equal to 100?
And the answer is no.
You can't possibly have more
than 1/3 of the population
have an IQ of 300, because if
more than 1/3 had an IQ of 300,
then that third alone
would contribute 1/3 of 300
to the average, which
would be greater than 100.
So you can't have more
than 1/3 of the population
have an IQ of triple the
expected value of the IQ.
So that's the basic bound.
So we can restate it this way.
The probability that a
randomly chosen person
has an IQ greater than or
equal to 100 we can say
is absolutely less than or equal
to the expected value of IQ,
namely 100 divided by 300.
And just parameterizing
it, if we ask,
what's the probability
that the IQ is
greater than or equal
to some amount x,
it's less than or equal to
100/x by exactly that reasoning.
And this is basically
Markov's bound,
except there's one
implicit fact that we're
using in deriving the previous
identity, or inequality,
that IQ is bounded by 100.
Our logic was that you can't
have more than population x
with an IQ of more
than 100x, because that
would contribute x times
100/x, or more than 100
to the average.
And the average is only 100.
That's only a problem if
there are no negative terms,
negative IQs, to offset
the excess contribution
of the fraction of
the population that
has this high IQ.
But we're implicitly using the
fact that IQ is never negative.
IQ runs from zero up
to unlimited amount.
But it's never negative.
And that means that
that contribution
from the 1/3 of the population
that has an IQ of over 300
can't be offset by
negative values.
It's there, and it
messes up the average.
It forces the average up.
So we were using the fact that
IQ is always non-negative.
And by this very
same reasoning, I'm
not going to belabor you
with a more formal proof.
There's a trivial
one in the text.
It's easy.
The theorem, Markov's bound,
says that if R is non-negative,
then the probability
that R is greater than
or equal to x is less than or
equal to the expectation of R
divided by x.
And this holds for
any x greater than 0.
Of course, it's silly
to state if this bound
is greater than or equal to 1.
It's not an interesting bound,
since probability is never
greater than or equal to 1.
So we might as well
just restrict ourselves
to x's that are greater
than the expectation of R,
because those are
the only x's that
are going to give us a
nontrivial bound that's
less than 1.
Again, if R is non-negative,
then the probability
that R exceeds an
amount x is less than
or equal to the
expectation of R over x.
And that's the Markov bound.
If you restate it in terms
of deviation from the mean,
you could formulate
it this way--
the probability
that R is greater
than or equal to a constant
times its mean-- mu is
an abbreviation for the
expectation of R-- is less than
or equal to 1/c.
So now, we can understand
that as a bound
on the deviation from the mean--
above the mean, in this case--
that R, as the factor of
the expectation increases,
the probability
decreases proportionally.
So the probability that R
is greater equal to 3 times
the expected amount is less than
or equal to 1/3, which was what
we saw with the IQ example.
So look, this Markov bound,
in general, is very weak.
As I said, I don't think
there's ever been an IQ recorded
that was as high as 300.
And in almost all the
examples that you come across,
there'll be other
information that
allows you to deduce tighter
bounds on the probability
that a random variable
is significantly
bigger than its expectation.
But if you don't
have any information
about the random variable, other
than that it's non-negative,
then as a matter of fact,
Markov bound is tight.
You can't possibly reach
a stronger contribution,
because there are non-negative
random variables where
the probability that
they are greater
than or equal to
a given amount x
is, in fact, equal to their
expectation divided by x.
So the Markov bound is
weak in application,
but it's the strongest
condition you
can make on the very
limited hypotheses
that it makes about properties
of the random variable.
And it's also pretty obvious,
I hope from this example
that we've talked about,
but the amazing thing
is how useful it is.
We will get mileage out of it
by using it in clever ways.
So let's talk about
the first clever way.
And suppose that we're
thinking about IQ
is greater than or equal to 100.
But I bring into the
story another fact
that we haven't mentioned
before, which is,
let's suppose that as a matter
of fact, IQs of less than 50
just don't occur.
I think they might
actually, but there's
a certain point where you just
are not functioning at all.
And it's not clear
that it makes sense
to ever talk about
somebody who's in a coma
as having an IQ.
Maybe they have an IQ of 0.
But let's assume that
pragmatically IQ is never
less than or equal to 50.
Now, if I tell you
that I know that IQ
is greater than or
equal to 50, then I
can actually get a better
bound out of Markov.
Because now, knowing that IQ
is greater than or equal to 50,
IQ minus 50 becomes a
non-negative random variable,
which I couldn't be
sure it was before,
because IQ might
have gone below 50.
Now that I know that it's
always above 50, IQ minus 50
is non-negative.
And Markov's bound will
apply to IQ minus 50.
And applying it to IQ minus 50
will give you a better bound.
Because now, looking
at the probability
that the IQ is greater than or
equal to 100, of course, that's
the same as saying
that IQ minus 50
is greater than or
equal to 300 minus 50,
which 50-- the average
expected value of IQ minus 50
is 100 minus 50.
So we're asking whether this is
non-negative random variable is
greater than or equal to 250.
And the answer is,
that's less than
or equal to its expectation
over 250, which is 1/5, 50/250.
And that's a tighter bound
than the 1/3 we had previously.
This is a general
phenomenon that you get
and that helps you get slightly
stronger bounds out of Markov's
bound, namely if you have
a non-negative variable,
you get a better bound
on it by shifting it
so that its mean is 0.
As a matter of fact,
even if it goes negative,
if you shift it up,
if you can force
it to become above
0 as a minimum,
then you can apply
Markov's bound to it.